there's a guy who called us his name is
Bobo and Gary sees him in every
appearance he does and he said to Bobo
Bobo
why do you wear the worst hairpiece in
the world and Bobo said it's not a bad
hairpiece people can't even tell I wear
one most people don't even know three
guys you're gonna walk in here one of
them is Bobo we've never met Bobo so we
wouldn't know Bobo from a hole in the
well let me ask you something are they
all wearing hairpieces or just no just
Bobo he says if we can guess who he is
he'll take off his hairpiece once and
for all
yeah oh there's some consequences mm-hmm
all right quickly bring in the three men
there's a guy number one there's guy
number two and guy number three
well I already know
I can tell already who's wearing the bad
hair priest but hi Bobo yeah all right
you say sir you claim you're Bobo yes
I'm are can you say you're wearing a bed
you see you're wearing a good hairpiece
and we'll never be able to tell the
difference none better all right and you
sir you claim you are Bobo your name oh
yeah you see you're Bobo yes and you say
you're wearing a hairpiece and no one
can tell that's right and number three
you claim to be Bobo I'm Bobo you say
you're Bobo and you have a hairpiece and
nobody can tell right excellent
now two of these guys have their real
hair right all right very obvious who
wants it so who wants to say who Bobo is
first how do we play you want to go who
do you think is Bobo number two is Bobo
the guy in the middle right that's I
mean it's just it's a fake looking thing
what do you say Jackie well I know one
of these guys but it wouldn't make any
difference I gotta tell you something
the guy on the right the heavyset guy
well I don't think he's Bobo he's got
pretty bad here I wouldn't be surprised
if he was wearing a hairpiece quite
frankly but Bobo's got the hairpiece the
guy in the middle number two Fred what
do you think oh come on he's had got a
hat on
all right you know we always joke
because we say guys you wear and that is
your real hair over there you know you
look like you got fake hair to number
two yeah like John said I could see a
fifty feet coming down the road you know
I don't think it's that bad you'd have
to be in a plane the thing is we always
see guys with bad hair pieces and
they're the last ones to know their bed
you mean you look in the mirror you
really think that looks good when I was
in the green room before the girl in it
didn't even know she picked him she did
yeah what happens when you out on a
windy day no problem are you shocked
that we could all could tell in two
seconds that you were Bobo I tell you
how it some people can some people can
I'm more people here we're not experts
could tell this cost me over $2,000 when
you say that and then you have to go for
maintenance don't you have maintenance
it's like thirty dollars a month 30 does
so this is about two grand a year
why do you know you know in all
seriousness I think you'd look better if
you just tape the two thousand dollars -
yeah
I'm telling you girls would like that
pull up some of your toupee let me see
what it looks like come on Bobo let's
see that's it I'm not taking it off
there's no price to take this off all
right sure there is no there's no price
how does it attach a clip maybe should
leave that on what do you do I'm a
defensive driving struck safety a
defensive driving instructor yeah give
the courses for 10% off the insurance
you know when you have problem you teach
people how to drive yeah and I get the
classroom instruction if you have points
any license want to get it removed you
must be a great driver also a big
memorabilia collector wait I got a host
shrine it huh what's the most valuable
Howard Stern thing you own well I got
the big poster and have it signed to you
I'll leave when you need one right I got
that okay Stan uh you know frame I
wonder what it's like when you find that
your driving instructor has like a big
shrine to Howard Stern doesn't bother me
what doesn't bother doesn't people know
cuz you don't know how many people I
work in a building of 1,600 people right
everybody knows me like this
I don't know so relieved you mean if you
walked in one day bald it would be too
shocking to people forget I said there's
no price to take this off right
everybody and I was listening achieve
right now if you took it off with us
you'd feel better and then everyone
would know and then indeed done with
that stupid thing and you can wash your
head and go swim in and feel the water
on your scalp you shower with it nice
yeah are you married
no he's divorce not cleaned out didn't
take that toupee though
[Laughter]